When we talk about facts,
we're referring to events that can be measured and quantified.
They generally provide a numerical answer to what or how much.
Stuff like what is the average number of hours worked in January?
Or how much has Store 110 sold year to date?
Imagine being in a grocery store checkout and scanning each individual product.
Every beep of the scanner would signify a new fact and a new row
being created in a grocery store's fact table of sales transactions.
Facts come in several flavors.
They can be additive, semi-additive, or non-additive.
Let's review them one by one.
Additive facts mean that each individual fact can be logically measured
using the descriptive data from
any dimension and that they will logically work for your reporting.
These are most facts.
They're things like quantity,
sales, invoice amounts, hours worked. You get the picture.
It's stuff you add up.
Semi-additive facts are a little bit different.
They can be calculated with some dimensions but not others.
Some examples that came to mind are inventory counts.
For example, you can add up inventory counts across stores, but not days.
Bank account balances.
If you think of your own bank account balance, for example,
you wouldn't add up yesterday's balance to today's and expect that
that total opening balance for tomorrow be the sum of both.
Though, of course, that would be very nice.
The same is true for accounts receivable
balances and other organizational balances such as accounts payable.
Really any other fact that represents
some cumulative snapshot is going to fall into this category.
Most common examples of semi-additive facts are values
that have some daily balance that can't be added up over the course of time.
Although I'm sure there are exceptions to this rule.
On to non-additive facts.
Non-additive facts are facts you need for reporting or calculations,
but you don't want to be add up.
A few examples are percentage discounts,
unit prices, or profit margin.
These are all instances where you might want the numbers to calculate sales
or profit or some other key performance indicator.
But you wouldn't want to sum them together.
It wouldn't make any sense for you to sum up all your percentage discounts,
for example, and get 5,260 percent.
Keep an eye out for non-additive facts that may sit better in a dimension table.
If a unit price is tagged to a specific item and unlikely to change,
you may be better off keeping that tracked and
maintained in a product dimension than on your fact table.
This is one of those judgment calls that depends on a variety of factors.
But it's good to keep in mind as an option if you need it.